et sur la table, il y a 76 objets,
qui peuvent procurer du plaisir ou de la douleur.
On trouve par exemple
un verre d'eau, un manteau, une chaussure, une rose,
mais aussi un couteau, une lame de rasoir, un marteau,
et un pistolet chargé d'une balle.
Il y a aussi des instructions :
« Je suis un objet.
Vous pouvez utiliser sur moi tout ce qui se trouve sur la table.
Je prends toute la responsabilité, même si vous me tuez.
Je resterai six heures. »
Au début, la performance était facile.
Les gens me faisaient boire
ou me donnaient la rose.
Mais rapidement,
un homme a pris les ciseaux et a découpé mes vêtements ;
d'autres ont arraché les épines de la rose et les ont plantées dans mon ventre.
Quelqu'un a pris la lame de rasoir, m'a coupé le cou, et a bu mon sang.
J'ai encore la cicatrice.
Les femmes disaient aux hommes ce qu'ils devaient faire.
Les hommes ne m'ont pas violée parce que nous étions dans une exposition normale,
dans un espace public,
et que leurs femmes étaient là.
Ils m'ont promenée, fait monter sur la table,
et ont mis le couteau entre mes jambes.
Quelqu'un a pris le pistolet chargé, et l'a posé contre ma tempe.
Quelqu'un d'autre lui a pris, et ils ont commencé à se battre.
Et quand les six heures furent écoulées,
j'ai...
commencé à marcher vers le public.
Je ne ressemblais à rien.
J'étais à moitié nue, ensanglantée, mon visage était inondé de larmes.
Et ils se sont tous échappés, ils se sont enfuis.
Ils ne supportaient pas de me faire face, maintenant que je n'étais plus une chose.
Et ensuite,
ce qu'il s'est passé,
c'est que je suis rentrée à l'hôtel. Il était deux heures du matin.
Et...
je me suis regardée dans le miroir,
et j'avais une mèche de cheveux gris.
Bien,
vous pouvez retirer vos bandeaux.
Bienvenue dans le monde de la performance.
Tout d'abord, laissez-moi vous expliquer ce qu'est une performance.
Chaque artiste a sa propre définition,
mais la mienne est très simple.
Une performance est une construction mentale et physique,
que l'artiste effectue pendant un temps donné,
dans un espace donné, en présence d'un public,
et qu'à ce moment-là, il y a un dialogue d'énergie.
Le public et l'artiste collaborent dans la création.
La différence entre la performance et le théâtre est énorme.
Au théâtre, les couteaux ne sont pas des couteaux,
et le sang n'est que du ketchup.
Dans une performance, le sang est un matériau,
et la lame de rasoir ou le couteau sont des outils.
Le principe, c'est d'être là, dans la réalité.
On ne peut pas répéter une performance :
beaucoup de ces choses ne peuvent jamais être réalisées une seconde fois.
Et c'est très important. La performance...
Vous savez, tous les êtres humains ont peur de choses très simples.
Nous avons peur de souffrir, nous avons peur de la douleur,
nous avons peur de mourir.
Donc ce que je fais,
c'est mettre en scène ces peurs en face d'un public.
J'utilise votre énergie,
et avec elle, je peux repousser les limites de mon corps autant que possible.
Et ensuite, je me libère de ces peurs.
Je suis votre miroir.
Si je peux faire cela pour moi-même, vous pouvez le faire pour vous.
Après Belgrade, où je suis née,
je suis allée à Amsterdam.
Vous savez, je réalise des performances
depuis 40 ans maintenant.
A Amsterdam, j'ai rencontré Ulay,
et il est devenu mon compagnon.
Pendant 12 ans, nous avons réalisé des performances ensemble.
Vous voyez, le couteau, le pistolet et les balles,
je les transforme en amour et en confiance.
Pour faire ce genre de travail, il faut faire complètement confiance à l'autre,
parce que cette flèche est pointée sur mon cœur.
Donc tout cela, le cœur qui accélère, l'adrénaline qui monte, et tout le reste,
tout cela se résume à une confiance totale placée dans un autre être humain.
Notre relation a duré 12 ans,
et nous avons travaillé sur de nombreux sujets, aussi bien féminins que masculins.
Puis, comme toute relation a une fin, la nôtre s'est terminée.
Nous n'avons pas fait comme les gens normaux, se passer un coup de fil
et dire : « C'est fini. »
Pour dire au revoir, nous avons marché sur la Grande Muraille de Chine.
Je suis partie de la mer Jaune, et lui du désert de Gobi.
Chacun de nous, pendant trois mois,
a marché 2 500 km.
C'était en montagne, c'était difficile.
Nous devions escalader, traverser des ruines.
Il fallait traverser les 12 provinces chinoises,
et c'était avant que la Chine rouvre ses frontières en 1987.
Et nous avons réussi à nous retrouver au milieu,
pour se dire au revoir.
Et notre relation a pris fin.
Tout cela a complètement changé la manière dont je vois le public.
Une des créations très importantes que j'ai faites à cette époque
est « Balkan Baroque. »
C'était à l'époque des guerres de Yougoslavie,
et je voulais créer une image forte, marquante,
qui pourrait s'appliquer n'importe quand, à n'importe quelle guerre,
car les guerres de Yougoslavie sont terminées, mais la guerre existe encore.
Donc je nettoie
2 500 gros os de vache, encore sanglants.
On ne peut pas nettoyer le sang, on ne peut pas nettoyer la honte des guerres.
Pendant 6 jours, 6 heures par jour, je frotte, et la guerre se détache des os.
Et cela devient possible. L'odeur est insupportable.
Mais au moins, quelque chose reste dans les mémoires.
Je veux vous montrer celle qui a vraiment changé ma vie.
C'était la performance au MoMa, que j'ai faite récemment.
Cette perfomance... Quand j'ai dit au conservateur :
« Je vais juste m'asseoir sur une chaise,
en face de laquelle il y aura une autre chaise,
et les gens pourront venir et s'asseoir aussi longtemps qu'ils veulent.»
Le conservateur m'a dit :
« C'est ridicule. Vous savez, on est à New-York.
La chaise restera vide,
personne n'a le temps de s'asseoir
devant vous. » (Rires)
Mais je l'ai fait, pendant trois mois.
Chaque jour, je me suis assise pendant 8h,
pendant les heures d'ouverture,
et donc 10h le vendredi,
sans jamais bouger.
J'ai enlevé la table, et j'ai continué à rester assise.
Cette performance a tout changé.
Il y a 10 ou 15 ans,
il ne se serait rien passé.
Mais les gens ont besoin de ressentir quelque chose de différent.
Le public n'était plus un groupe...
C'était une expérience individuelle.
Je regardais ces gens qui venaient s'asseoir en face de moi,
et qui avaient attendu pendant des heures et des heures
pour obtenir cette place,
pour pouvoir enfin s'asseoir.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
Ils étaient observés par d'autres gens,
ils étaient photographiés, filmés,
je les observais aussi,
et ils n'avaient nulle part où se réfugier, à part en eux-mêmes.
Et cela faisait toute la différence.
Il y a tant de solitude, de souffrance,
de choses incroyables, quand on regarde quelqu'un dans les yeux.
Parce que dans le regard de cet inconnu,
qui ne dit pas un mot, tout se passe.
Et quand je me suis levée de cette chaise au bout de trois mois, j'ai compris
que je n'étais plus la même.
Et j'ai compris que j'avais une mission très importante :
je devais partager cette expérience
avec tout le monde.
Et c'est comme ça que m'est venue l'idée
d'ouvrir un institut des arts immatériels de la performance.
Quand on réfléchit à la question de l'immatérialité,
la performance s'appuie sur le temps.
Ce n'est pas un tableau.
Un tableau sur un mur y sera encore le lendemain.
Quand on a manqué une performance, on n'en a que le souvenir,
ou le récit que quelqu'un nous en a fait,
mais on l'a quand même manquée.
Il faut être là.
A mon avis, quand on parle des arts immatériels,
la musique est le plus important de tous les arts,
car elle est la plus immatérielle.
Ensuite vient cette performance, puis tout le reste.
C'est mon opinion.
Cet institut ouvrira à Hudson, au nord de New-York,
et avec Rem Koolhaas, nous nous appuyons sur une idée.
Elle est très simple.
Si vous voulez réaliser cette expérience, vous devez me donner votre temps.
Avant d'entrer dans le bâtiment, vous devez signer le contrat
qui stipule que vous allez y passer six heures d'affilée.
Vous devez me donner votre parole d'honneur.
C'est très vieux-jeu,
mais si vous ne respectez pas votre propre parole d'honneur, et partez avant,
ce n'est pas mon problème.
L'expérience dure six heures.
Une fois terminées, vous obtenez un certificat de complétion,
que vous pouvez afficher chez vous si vous voulez.
(Rires)
Voici le hall d'orientation.
C'est là que le public entre. La première chose à faire est d'enfiler une blouse.
Il est important
de passer du statut de simple spectateur à celui d'expérimentateur.
Vous allez ensuite dans les vestiaires,
où vous déposez votre montre, votre iPhone, votre iPod, votre ordinateur,
tout ce qui est digital, électronique.
Et pour la première fois, vous avez du temps pour vous.
Ce n'est pas que la technologie soit quelque chose de mauvais ;
c'est notre approche qui est mauvaise.
Nous perdons du temps que nous pourrions consacrer à nous-même.
Dans cet institut, nous vous rendons ce temps.
Ce que vous faites ici,
c'est d'abord de marcher doucement. Vous commencez par ralentir.
Vous retournez à la simplicité.
Après la marche lente, vous allez réapprendre à boire de l'eau.
C'est très simple, vous buvez de l'eau, pendant environ une demi-heure.
Ensuite, vous allez dans la chambre magnétique,
où vous allez créer des courants magnétiques sur votre corps.
Puis, vous passez dans la chambre des cristaux.
Puis dans la salle des regards,
puis dans une chambre où vous pouvez vous allonger.
On a donc les trois positions de base du corps humain :
assis, debout, et couché.
Plus la marche lente,
et une salle insonorisée.
Et une fois que vous avez vu tout ça,
que vous vous êtes préparés mentalement et physiquement,
vous êtes prêts à voir quelque chose qui dure longtemps,
comme l'art immatériel.
Cela peut-être un concert, un opéra, une pièce de théâtre,
un film, une vidéo de danse.
Vous allez dans les fauteuils de longue durée, et maintenant vous êtes bien.
Dans les chaises de longue durée,
on vous transporte jusqu'à l'endroit où vous allez voir la performance.
Et si vous vous endormez,
ce qui est très possible, car la journée a été longue,
vous serez emmenés sur le parking des dormeurs.
(Rires)
Vous savez, le sommeil est très important.
Même quand vous dormez, vous êtes réceptifs à l'art.
Donc, vous restez dans le parking des dormeurs un moment,
et après, vous retournez juste
pour voir plus de choses,
ou vous rentrez chez vous avec votre attestation.
Pour l'instant, cet institut n'existe pas.
J'en prépare un au Brésil,
puis ce sera en Australie,
puis ici, au Canada, et partout.
Cela permet de faire l'expérience d'une méthode simple,
qui vous permet de retrouver la simplicité dans votre vie.
On comptera aussi des grains de riz.
(Rires)
Vous savez, en comptant des grains de riz, vous pouvez mener votre vie.
Comment compter du riz pendant 6 heures ?
C'est incroyablement important.
Vous passez par toutes les émotions : l'ennui, la colère,
la frustration de ne pas réussir à finir votre tas de riz,
et puis arrive cette paix incroyable
quand vous avez effectué un travail satisfaisant.
C'est comme compter le sable du désert.
Ou être insonorisé :
vous avez un casque sur les oreilles, et vous n'entendez rien.
Vous restez tous ensemble sans son,
avec des gens qui font l'expérience du silence. Juste du silence.
Nous faisons toujours des choses qui nous plaisent,
et c'est pour ça que nous ne changeons pas.
Nous faisons des choses...
Rien ne se passe si vous faites toujours tout de la même façon.
Ma méthode est de faire les choses qui me font peur,
celles que je ne connais pas,
d'aller là où personne n'est allé.
Et cela inclut aussi l'échec.
Je pense que l'échec est important,
car quand on expérimente, on peut échouer.
Si on n'essaye pas, et qu'on n'échoue pas,
on ne fait que se répéter, encore et encore.
Et je pense que maintenant les gens ont besoin de changer,
et que le seul changement à faire est au niveau personnel.
C'est à vous d'effectuer ce changement.
Car le seul moyen de changer les esprits
et le monde autour de nous
est de commencer par soi-même.
Il est facile de critiquer les choses qui diffèrent
dans le monde, et qui ne sont pas bonnes,
et les gouvernements corrompus, et les famines,
et les guerres, les massacres.
Mais ce que nous faisons, d'un point de vue individuel...
Quelle est notre contribution à ce tout ?
Tournez-vous vers votre voisin, celui que vous ne connaissez pas,
et regardez-le dans les yeux pendant deux minutes.
(Brouhaha)
Je vous demande deux minutes de votre temps, c'est si peu.
Respirez calmement, essayer de ne pas trop cligner, de ne pas avoir honte.
Détendez-vous.
Regardez juste cet inconnu dans les yeux.
(Silence)
Merci pour votre confiance.
(Applaudissements)
Chris Anderson : Merci.
Merci beaucoup.